so i talked to a rich dude i know
and he said that he loves to recruit
losing congressional candidates to the
non-profits that he runs
because he thinks that the folks who run
are really talented often they lose you
know not because they're like not great
candidates but just because of
very structural things yeah and he
thinks that the skill set lends itself
very very nicely to
growing nonprofits politics and
nonprofits
we've learned firsthand it's like about
the founder right um and it falls around
the person helps the narrative i mean if
you can get
critical mass let's call it more than 10
to 20 percent of the vote and some of
these things and that's remarkable the
party then becomes something that people
will be like oh i should pay attention
to this because that's the way the
american system works it's like nobody
cares unless you're a threat
unless you can be real
[Music]
this week on forward big announcements
read the podcast the january 6 hearings
politics versus non-profits versus
business should you surprise your
significant other when you propose a
career in comedy so much to talk about
this week on forward
[Music]
this is going to be the final thursday
episode of me and zach for quite a while
um when i say quite a while the summer
we're looking at like a summer hiatus
um just want to say
first uh how much
fun i've had hanging out with you zach
uh and
for everyone who's been listening
uh really grateful really appreciative i
hope you feel like you've been
on this journey with us so why are we
we uh
not recording for much of the summer
number one is that both zach and i are
going to be traveling a fair amount um
and so if you're not in the same place
then what are we going to do like zoom
and be like hey like we'll shoot the
[ __ ] over zoom it just didn't seem
uh that the same um but also
um we think that
we could all use a little bit of a break
over the summer like everyone needs a a
a respite and a hiatus bigger picture
um we have projects in the offing that
may take us to periods where frankly we
have like you know full-time
uh hands-on
operating roles no offense but we're
going to have better [ __ ] to do than to
talk to you no
i will never have better
but how about just talk we've got stuff
to do and not talk about that yeah
because like at root zach and i are both
operators entrepreneurs builders now uh
in my case what i'm building first and
foremost is the forward party new
political movement which is growing by
leaps and bounds we're gonna have
exciting announcements for you um but in
zack's case he might build an
honest-to-god company that we'll have
um very exciting announcements for you
on but first he has to go to the lab for
a while and we gotta go we're gonna make
this thing i think people's people say
they're working on a stealth company
like you're so special you can't talk
about it but
it is smart to keep it under wraps until
we
figure out how we're selling it and how
the launches and things like that so a
few more months but you guys will be
honestly probably the first to know so
yeah yeah we'll bring back uh zach so we
can talk about this exciting new company
that he's working on um that i will be
uh
more than cheering for i mean i'll be
helping you force andrew to stay
involved in most of the stuff yeah i
mean you know i can increase the chances
of success of a lot of things
for sure one of the fun things so uh so
summer break
from the andrew and zach uh
perspective um i i know you've all been
um waiting for a bro
but
bigger picture me and zach are still
uh doing great things you just have to
we just have to go take the summer to go
uh bake some stuff in the oven back to
the lab again yeah january 6 30 let's do
january 6. i'm not watching this [ __ ]
and i know you're i've watched a little
bit on twitter
i've quote followed a little bit on
twitter yeah yeah i i also have not been
um
watching the bulk of the hearings i've
been getting like synthesis and news
accounts and social media
uh clips and whatnot and
um so here's my take on it right large
but i think a lot of americans are um so
i'm in the camp that the insurrection
was very very serious
uh and lives were lost and people
should be held accountable i am also of
the opinion
that
this
set of hearings has become
kind of this political theater that is
not necessarily going to result in
referrals to the department of justice
or
legal proceedings against very various
folks and i think some of the
uh committee members have even said as
much saying like oh it's not our job to
refer
um and the unfortunate thing is that
there are a couple ways this could have
gone number one is
um you have
a lot of responsible republicans raising
their hand saying hey and you have a
handful i mean you have like the leaders
of the anti-trump
um and i was about to say wing of the
party but it's not a wing i mean it's
literally rainfall it's so it's liz
cheney's adam kensinger um sometimes uh
yeah occasionally someone else sticks
their head in um i mean like the and and
i do want to take a a quick detour and
say look um there were 10
republican house members who voted to
impeach trump that number was apparently
35
just hours before the vote but they all
got death threats via um
via text message and then the number
went from 35 to 30 to 25 and then even
when it came down to the last 10 a lot
of them weren't sure what they were
going to do because they were all
getting so much pressure not to vote
that way so then 10 did vote that way
and of those 10 four have retired
including kinzinger one just lost in
south carolina so again when you say
like wing of the party you're talking
about at this point there are literally
only five five house members um and and
that number could go down um pretty
quick over this next period of time um
so you don't have a truly
broad
bipartisan
um
uh approach to these hearings um it it
it was
uh you know run for tv
by essentially the democratic party
and so to me like the single biggest
question is like will there be legal
proceedings against various figures um
do i personally think that there should
be legal accountability yes i do like
you don't need to convince me of this
stuff like i know it was messed up um
the thing you need to convince me of is
is there going to be real accountability
or are you just trying to make your case
for public consumption
the left in particular while trump was
president and since he's left have
they're
you'd watch an msnbc or cnn
piece and they're like
this is the bombshell that'll turn the
tide against trump this is the thing
they don't want you to see this is gonna
change everything and they've said that
over and over we've all seen it for one
thing or another whether it's xyz
whistleblower or this and nothing has
ever the big thing was the mueller
report the mueller report yeah that's a
great one it's freaking the best example
yeah it was and literally a nothing
burger and it's over and over nothing
burger and it's not like nothing that
there wasn't anything wrong it's just
that this don't these aren't don't turn
into actual prosecutions now let me ask
you is that because
the wrong doings are not that bad or is
that look
politics governing is messy anything you
do on the right over here is stuff that
the left is doing too so if you actually
prosecute me we're going to flip the you
know
flip the script right back on you as
soon as we're back in power and no one
wants to open that can of worms well you
know i think that you have um
like a degree of just institutional
weakness
where
uh if there was let's say political
consensus let's imagine a world where
the republicans had joined hands and
said hey um trump this is beyond the
pale uh you need to be held accountable
right and then everyone was rallying
around uh
doj
yeah prosecutions cancer yeah and and
and the rest of it yeah uh would it
happen in that world
yeah i think it would
um the world we're in right now is that
you have a deeply divided government
um and so then the the democrats feel
like hey if we bring this it's going to
be decried as a partisan um hack job
certainly trump's going to according to
say that right um and and then
it becomes a much more difficult choice
for
the the various officials and you so you
would need a set of officials with
certain disposition um
certain
frankly courage
and
i
feel like that's kind of lacking they're
much more likely to
uh say this falls into a gray area and
let it go um and then things fall into
again this political
uh
realm where
certain people think like oh you know
wasn't that serious and then others
uh think that people should be you know
like sent to jail for it right
so yet again we'll have a whole bunch of
resources time money energy people
fundraising around this
i'll tell you when i talk about donald
trump running for president again like a
lot of democrats look at me and say hey
like but won't he be in jail by then
won't he be indicted by then and and i'm
just like well i'll believe it when i
see it you know what i mean like people
have been talking about this for a
freaking ever since before he was
running since before since he was the
nominee
you know the best let's call it
bait case i've seen has been frankly
like tax evasion tax fraud in new york
new york new york city that stuff's
legit um
that's how they got capone if you will
uh they didn't get them for actual
crimes in that sense and murders and
things like that they got them for
uh tax evasion um
so
maybe but i'm with you man like it's
uh
our system's crumbling it's not really
working um a lot of forces working
against it i wanted to bring this up
because um one if you're on the left and
you're getting
let's call it democratic leaning or
highly fueled messaging you're seeing
all these hearings over and over and
being told trump's on his last rope and
xyz and if you're on the right you're
probably not seeing this at all like fox
is barely covering it
um
and they're not even the far right
anymore let's call it you know the other
like your daily wires and bright parts
and
further and further right they're not
touching it right so
the reality is we probably get nothing
you know it's probably a lot of again
for me it's like i will believe it when
the legal proceedings uh are
brought to bear and until then i'm just
like wake me up until yeah you know let
me know as real yeah
what are you sleeping on right now
seriously i want you to think about it
because i used to not give any time or
thought to my mattress and then i got a
helix mattress and i'm telling you this
it's freaking remarkable helix
mattresses some of the most comfortable
mattresses on the market and they're
fantastic so how it works does helix
sleep has a quiz that just takes about
two minutes to complete imagine your
body type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you so why would
you buy a mattress made for someone else
get one made for you and with helix
you're getting a mattress that you know
be the perfect way for you to sleep
everybody's unique helix knows that so
there's lots of different mattresses and
models to choose from so i got one
that's like medium firmness because i
sleep on my side all the time it's
perfect for me cannot complain and my
brother who's just casually sleeping
over loves it as well this mattress is
freaking gold but you don't take my word
for it it's been awarded the number one
best overall mattress pick of 2020 by gq
and wired magazine all you have to do is
go to helixsleep.com
yang take their two minute sleep quiz
and they'll match you to a customized
mattress that'll give you the best sleep
of your life for real they have a 10
year warranty and you get to try it out
for a hundred nights risk free so helix
right now is offering up to 200
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows and they're lovely for our
listeners that's helix sleep.com
yang helixsleep.com
[Music]
we don't always have to talk about elon
musk on this podcast but he said
something uh i think a lot of people are
thinking but we haven't really talked
about really since you ran for maybe may
or a bit i think you talked about it but
a bit on president um the presidential
race was tick-tock he said it's uh
essentially destroying civilization we
have a lot of young people spending a
lot of time and energy and it's not like
a small subset it's a lot it's i mean
you have kids that are getting closer
it's the number one platform um
spending a lot of time energy
focused on tick tock what are the
consequences of that
for this generation is it as bad as
people say they are are we overblown
you know talking oh the kids are you
know this is old people complain about
the kids is it that bad or is it um
overbought
tick tock is a very very addictive place
to be you know i'm on tick tock i don't
sit there and uh scroll on tick tock
very often um but when i do it's
hypnotic
so what i what i see is like kids just
going in you know going into tick tock
um
consumption mode and just tuning out and
you're just like hypnotized by music and
typically young people and catchy videos
and they're short and then even if
you're not loving it like the next video
starts
so so what does this mean in terms of
young people
i'm a parent i've got two kids and the
main thing i want my kids to do is read
books
and it's not really happening
for them you know they'd much rather
play a quick video game or whatnot so
tick-tock to me is an extension of that
it's that you have
consumption habits and attention span
durations that are going to shift
in a particular way i mean like tick
tock a couple things that i don't love
about it and social media in general but
tic tocs like that seems to be the
pinnacle so far uh
where you don't have to connect with the
people around you like you could have no
friends around you but millions of
people following you on the app and feel
like you get that positive
connection and dopamine from a million
but actually millions actually have no
friends and i don't think that's a good
thing
i think it prioritizes like short-term
gains like doing something for like a
click or a like and if
it's the marshmallow test right where
delayed gratification is one of the
biggest indicators of successful people
and i feel like this cuts strongly in
the opposite direction
um so i worry about the impact of that
and i also worry about these kids
like spending a lot of time and energy
and resources and something that really
isn't doing much it's adding i guess
maybe sparks of joy but it's not really
adding much value except distraction so
i worry about
that you know and how it's if i was a
kid that'd be shaping my mind in my
social scene well we're rewiring kids
brains and myriad ways uh and tick tock
is the latest progression my running
joke is that i'm going to start a
billion dollar app to replace tik tok
and it's going to be called tick
and the maximum video length is one
second
so
watch out tick tock
tick is coming's coming for you
all right man so
uh
we have been recording um
these convos since october so it's
approximately
nine months or so in the studio in the
studio yeah
you and me yep so in that time
you've had some major life events
you've gotten engaged to be married yep
uh you've become a published author it's
true it's been a been a fun nine months
or whatever
um
uh you and i have traveled to
um miami and austin together
um
[Music]
uh
what are your favorite memories of the
last nine months it can be in the
podcast or outside the podcast aside
from i mean we can talk about getting
engaged and uh becoming an author so
that was great um
were you were you sure she was going to
say yes i'm sure she was going to say
yes nice which is good i highly
recommend that folks if you're going to
propose to someone talk about it
beforehand no dude dude like so i
proposed to evelyn you were not sure
right you weren't okay i proposed to
evelyn and here here here was the only
uh bar i set for myself was that she has
to not know it's coming okay
and so i genuinely surprised the [ __ ]
out of her that's good like really like
kind of speechless uh kind of thing and
then her response at uh verbatim was why
are you doing this
really
maybe we talked about that before yeah
five words five words you don't want to
hear when you're proposing honestly no
you don't want to hear anything but yes
yep
carly said of course which i asked it
wasn't yes but i mean that's it's pretty
good man of course it's freaking dope
you're just hoping for yes right
um so uh what you're not hoping for is
why are you doing this um eventually we
got to yes
but this was one of the costs to my
surprising her um and i'd packed the
wedding ring and i had a little cartoon
to propose uh you know we went to
caribbean island but she genuinely
didn't see it coming like evelyn i had
this like this running joke where she
said why are you doing this because she
was like i'm like too young and at the
time she was not that young i mean she
was like a fine marriageable age it was
a lot like a child bride situation i
mean she was
28 at the time of proposal
that's young that's a good age uh so she
said yes and then
um
celebrations ensued
uh
so that would probably be uh fond memory
number one of the last nine months for
you like what else is in there um
related to the podcast i loved our
conversations on
boys and men
um i loved uh i loved your conversation
with john mcquarter i thought that was
good on woke racism um
but yeah the boys and men stuff i think
was the most eye opening and then the
other thing i'll say that i don't think
i've talked about in this podcast but um
we're trying to get we haven't been able
to get him on maybe we will but this guy
james clear wrote a book called atomic
habits and that book has changed my life
atomic habits by james clear
um i've been trying to break couple
habits i've been snoozing too much i
haven't been working out as much as i
wanted and i
the third one is i bite my nails trying
to get rid of that and he like
there's a book called the power habit
very popular and he like takes that one
step further and it's very very tactical
which i like um
and so i'm not perfect but the book is
dynamite um
so that has been
honestly a game changer like a different
perspective on life it's rare i read a
book where it's shapes like that so
that's
probably the stuff for me outside of
life event um
i'm continuously
tweeting out uh my conversation with
barbara walter about how civil wars
start in part because civil war is
trending on twitter every fourth day and
then i'm like uh i had twitter um which
by the way so there was a period when
only conservatives were allowed to talk
about civil war and then liberals were
like oh by talking about that you're you
know awful um
i don't know if you knew that was a
thing i didn't i did i mean didn't
surprise me but i didn't yeah no the
liberals were like by talking about
civil war you are like causing it yeah
you're causing it you're terrible you're
words um words are evil and then now now
liberals are like hey you know civil
war's on the table and uh barbara walter
was one of the reasons for this there
there were two authors stephen marsh
and barbara walter
so stephen martin's book was the next
civil war and barbara walters how civil
wars start
so there's kind of companion books
barbara walter had the advantage of
being like a phd in political science
where she like unpacked all of the
trends and she went on starting them
internationally so that framework i
found to be very very helpful
uh john mcmorner certainly i mean that
like that that dude to the extent that
they're someone who explained
the problem of uh kind of the weakness
thing um john mcwhorter is the man uh
you know he he like spelled it out for
me in a particular way um and the most
controversial thing he said was that he
compared it to a religion and that is
like a religious uh
uh
kind of
uh disposition and if you question it
and he said it's like look you don't try
and like convert someone out of a
religion like we just try and work
around them
and i thought that was highly
interesting
different people call but someone else
called it also the religious left
so you're right that was a highly
um powerful convo
during this time um i've been running
around
trying to build a forward party um and
the forward party i'm happy to say is
going to have some really exciting
announcements later this summer
but we're on the verge of being the
third biggest political party in the
country by resources within a year of
founding which i'm super excited about
yep uh and it was all because of this
podcast i know now i mean the podcast
i'm sure like you know i'm sure it did
help um
the boys in mencon were particularly
proud of you know i think i mentioned
that the op-ed i wrote in the washington
post
um is now going to be taught in ap
english uh in
classrooms around the country
um
as part of like uh an english textbook
that stuff does warm my heart where you
have there's some stuff you've done and
even i've done like i've had a couple
people mention me like i'm
i've had a professor's like i'm going to
teach some of the stuff in your in your
book and i and
in my book and then your book for sure i
get a lot more of those um and your your
war on people book um
so
academia is going in different
especially higher academias going in
different higher ed's going different
direction but
there are some
pockets of
uh
hope i'd say in terms of people studying
what we're talking about a little bit so
good which is good study long shot
study forward i think it's a good book
if you're running for offices
on her podcast generational change and
she's
i i like the way she ran she raised a
ton of money she got me and she got a
good number of votes she got like 27
percent of the vote in that primary
which is really impressive for a
first-time candidate yep um against jen
pearl was great debbie wasserman schultz
uh debbie last great continue yeah she
said a lot of her votes because
everybody hates her so much
you know she's like as running a
candidate like
my book talks about like are the
problems we had were problems that a lot
of people have across the country
they're running for first time that does
bring me hope that there are people
who take kind of what we say seriously
even though um we're not always the most
serious at times and um but also in the
midst of a lot of nonsense going on you
know
so i talked to a rich dude i know
and he said that he loves to recruit
losing congressional candidates
to the non-profits that he runs
because he thinks that the folks who run
are really talented often they lose you
know not because they're like not great
candidates but just because of various
structural things and he thinks that the
skill set lends itself very very nicely
to
growing non-profits i'd argue it lends
itself to a lot of things like if you
can run with your head held high and
outperform what you're expected which is
essentially
zero right i mean if you i mean if you
can get
critical mass let's call it more than
ten to twenty percent of the vote and
some of these things and that's
remarkable um you can raise certain
money so
the hustle and drive and leadership and
resilience and scrappiness like those
things translate almost any industry
right um but i agree like the nonprofit
spectre would help a lot because you're
always doing more with less and being
told no a lot well so check out check it
out both directions so i ran a
non-profit for six and a half years that
you
supported um you started a non-profit
it's a fun game
um the the
podcast on monday was with daniel
lubetsky who ran
a combo for-profit non-profit peace
works for 10 years
and i don't know if you heard on the
podcast but he was like hey this thing
was hand to mouth for 10 years we were
you know budgeted 2 million 3 million
then he starts kind and it just takes
off like a rocket more or less and then
now it's you know multi-billion dollar
business
and so there's something about like i i
ran a nonprofit and like it's very
difficult for non-profits to grow past a
certain point
like the the management acumen necessary
to
develop and grow and org is really
um
significant
uh and
a friend of mine said it to me best he
said non-profits run on passion yeah so
you're typically very passionate about
the cause and the org and so in my case
run nonprofit for six and a half years
conclude that the problems are too big
for my nonprofit to ever really solve
and so it's like well how could you
solve them
reorganize the economy how do you do
that run for president what are the
rules running for president et cetera et
cetera so i have seen people go from
pissed off non-profit founder to
political candidate because they're like
hey
like these problems are too big for my
non-profit to address
the the other direction so this is one
of the fundamental issues that we have
in life and this is something i struggle
with personally i think even you
struggle with so check it out
ceo of private company where your life
is normal you talk every once in a while
but it's not your main jam like you you
know
nonprofit you run something but you also
have to go around and sell people raise
money do a bunch of stuff yes and then
political candidate it's like all of
your stuff is external facing and you're
like barely an operator at all right
now the the problem that happens to us
is that if you have someone who's in the
political game for too long
and then then you say hey like you're
not going to be doing politics anymore
because you lost your seat right um
half of them right now become lobbyists
because it's like okay i've got these
relationships
like uh the the this um marketability in
a particular way but like now i don't
know how to run [ __ ]
you know i mean i'm not like uh
you know like uh i mean this this is
especially the with with tech now like
the software platforms you're using
around an organization change every
three to five years right
so and oh and by the way the average
member of congress is uh you know 58 uh
center 64. so if you're like losing your
race and you come out and you're like a
50-something year-old and somehow you
give you our team slack account like
your toast yeah someone's gonna pay you
half a million dollars to call you old
friends and uh you know control them
into taking meetings it's like oh that
seems like a better gig than uh yeah you
know um studying how to use monday or
using you're learning to use one of
these project management tools that all
the startups use yeah so so one of the
issues is that the political thing and
this is one reason why you
are heading uh to industry in the way
that you are which is by the way going
to be very wholesome and very
entrepreneurial and very scrappy and the
rest of it but you see that if you go
too deep down this road you're like oh
[ __ ] like i'm not going to be an
operator anymore correct i'm going to be
like a talking head
um communicator
person who then and there's a market for
that
um but the market you know is not as
good frankly as if if you can wrench it
and you're like a genuine
executive
well you've learned that too because
you've gone in the political game like
in like the field of uh
what's called democracy reform right and
there's a lot of people who name
nameless but they're they look good on a
website or
on a
panel or xyz but when you actually try
and get them to do anything they're not
that helpful um
they have some connections but it's
really they can get coffee with some
people they can't get resources at a
table they can't operate effectively
they can't market effectively it's just
you know um yeah completely agree um
the other thing is like one of my
biggest learnings when i was running a
nonprofit was
how much
like the there's the good idea
right the innovation
and i thought that would carry the day
and there's so much more of like
people's mentalities and perceptions and
other things that get in the way like
one of the biggest things
i was told
when i first started suit up was like i
had other non-profit folks be like we
don't need more education nonprofits
like please stop and i was like i think
you missed the point my my goal is to
the reason i wanted to start is not
because we need more of these correct
but we can actually unlock actual money
into this non-profit space which you
guys are all fighting for and don't do
it very well um
but
i mean i think i learned that we ran for
office i learned that random non-profit
where it's not just the innovation like
venture for america wonderful idea your
issues were
people and hesitations and like
getting buy-in and approval and
you know it wasn't just you couldn't
just be a you couldn't have a smart idea
and win the day you had to do a lot more
well around it what your friend mike
tarullo um said to me that actually
pushed me in a certain direction mike
gorilla you got me to run for president
united states without even knowing it
and here's how
so i'm hanging out in venture from
america hq with mike tarullo who's a a
schoolmate of
zach's back in the day and he was your
ceo he's like you're yeah
yeah yeah um and and so i get asked to
speak at a conference and i'm like you
know is my speaking at this conference
really going to help us
and then what mike said to me was it was
it was andrew for venture for america to
get to here
you have to be up here
it's like for venture of america to
become a thing andrew yang has to become
a thing yes and so when mike said that i
thought wow
he might be right
but also
hearing from my team that it was better
for them
for me to go to some conference and
spend a couple days away because like
that that helps us achieve our goals was
like permission you know i felt like
kind of a dick being like hey i'm going
to go jerk it at this conference for a
couple days you guys like do your thing
but then when when he was saying like uh
that helps us no that helps us like like
your trying to elevate your profile is
good for this organization um and
generally speaking he's right because
you needed someone to hook an idea onto
and despite learning that over six years
adventure for america
i still wanted to not
build the presidential campaign around
andrew yang in part because i was
running for president that was kind of
rash um but uh i you know was named ubi
2020 initially yeah the first name of
the campaign was ubi 2020 i was like i
don't think it works
yeah it's like you know we didn't have
logos
yeah yeah so zach can
vouch for this uh and so then we tested
it and then yang 2020 came back much
better
um and and but again even the fact that
i had to
uh to make a decision on that meant that
i really had not learned my lesson like
i already learned this lesson and then i
needed to relearn it again because like
i still wanted the ideas to lead i like
naturally want the ideas to lead but
like it's not the the
even with a forward party it's like the
idea is spot on it's like hey major
third party like we all know we need it
62 percent of americans want it like et
cetera et cetera but then everyone still
is like oh andrew yang
let's say i was some no name that could
not credibly run for president and get
you know last i checked something like
five to ten percent of the vote
then you know what you would think about
the forward party absolutely nothing
because you never heard of it just
because like you know there are half a
dozen other these little parties that
got started by people you've never heard
of and you never will hear of
so
so the fact that i'm someone who could
credibly launch a run and change the
math i mean you probably should no it
means that like that that the party then
becomes
something that people will be like oh i
should pay attention to this because
that's the way the american system works
it's like nobody cares unless you're a
threat
unless you can be real
um
and so in my case it's like yo so one of
the ironic things too is like if i would
just run around with my hand up in the
air and a bible in the other being like
i will not run for president like
no one would believe me anyway
you know what i mean like there's like
nothing
like you know it's like uh you know so
as it is
and like god's honest truth like i have
no idea what i'm gonna do and i'm like
just like open-minded about like you
know just trying to help the country so
like if it felt like it'd be good for
the country i'd like you know do what i
could um if getting behind someone else
is uh you know the way which my instinct
is that it's probably going to be
uh supporting
the party whatever that means
you know i'm we're having someone on the
podcast uh
um next week who like he's he's
definitively talking about running for
president a third party ticket so
um you know that like there are people
that i'm talking to
uh that
seem pretty excellent yeah
well uh
let me ask you so my number my number
one draft pick people probably know is
mark cuban so you know that is i think
he's a good pick
[Music]
let me ask you this um so politics and
non-profits
we've learned firsthand it's like about
the founder right
and it falls around the person helps the
narrative um but you said this i think
you said this on the trail a few times i
want to dive in it's like
if you're a ceo of a for-profit company
you're out there trying to get as much
press and awareness and build up your
own profile
usually that makes you a terrible ceo
your company's going to [ __ ] and that's
nine times out of ten
is that um
is the difference because
some of these non-profits and political
candidates aren't actually doing
anything they're just kind of pushing
moving [ __ ] around and because when
you're running an opera a business you
actually have to do something and make
the numbers work all right here's the
thing um and i i've now been this in a
in a couple of different capacities
so
when i was running for president the
highest use i could have
is to depress and
chase
coverage
and do things that drive energy because
the uh enemy is oblivion really you know
like you you have to
be enemies irrelevance oblivion yeah
yeah so
uh
now in a company's perspective in theory
the company is delivering something of
value
and if you're doing that and it's
significant enough then you could spend
all of your time honing operations and
trying to get your value proposition
better and managing your team and
organization
and that would be a much better use of
your time
than press that might result in growth
sure um you can be oblivious and make
money in companies if you will no no no
there are some companies that go into
growth mode
where then and the one that jumps jumps
in my mind for whatever reason is we
work yeah um where it you know when a
company goes into expansion mode and
then you're just like running around
trying to
um
in their in their case it was raise
money yeah um
but but it can be that sometimes you're
raising awareness
and this is something that i have done
for
for political campaigns uh sort of did
for organizations
um and so you do what the organization
needs
and if your company is operating well
then what it needs is for you to mind
the operations
you know go in i mean you can have a
great co i mean like like that that
would be phenomenal
um
that's so true you could run suit ups
operations fantastically it doesn't
always move the needle sometimes on the
presidential
not at all
um realistically yeah if you sat there
and like got your team running like a
well-oiled machine but like there was no
press coming in i know like the rest of
it then your campaign dies yeah what
what's funny too zach is that i you know
you remember this about me it's like if
someone asked me what was the happiest
time in my life professionally it was
like categorically just like anonymously
running a private company like life made
sense was great you know i met evelyn
during that time we were dating just
yucking it up i could make decisions to
do something uh and it would be you know
just frankly it happened the next day
and it was it was done
um
i mean i look back fondly on my time um
running venture for america but it was a
very difficult job yes um
you know really proud of it um i look
back finally in my time running for
president but wow that was like you know
[ __ ] hard that was hard
four parties not easy
ford party the podcast is fun
the podcast we're not particularly great
at it though we're like i appreciate you
guys listening but we're not we're not
the next joe rogan podcast i mean so so
zach's been a real anchor
um
on on my brilliance
[Music]
so i've been asked to give a couple
commencement speeches so i've been
thinking about guidance for the next
generation
i gave a
commencement address at columbia law
school where i graduated from um yeah
and did you see it i did
uh so i tried to throw the needle
between being
serious and inspirational and funny and
funny
because
i i don't know it was like it just did
not seem uh so and i confessed when i
was there i was like oh [ __ ] like you
know do i have to play this straight or
am i gonna
stick to
trying to
be funny um so you're certainly better
you're trying to be funny well thank you
man so i'm i'm considering and people
online can like talk to me about this
but i'm considering leaning into the
humor um in part because i feel like
america needs some levity because things
are [ __ ] depressing i would support
the andrew yang stand-up career dude i i
like i have half a dozen standing offers
from various clubs in new york just to
show up and do
like surprise sets work on a bit
i mean like i you know
there's a market for political humor
because a lot of people
you can't talk about politics anywhere
else
i was just that i'll say this i was at a
i went to a cocktail party this weekend
housewarming party
and we were talking about politics we're
talking about desantis and i said
something i don't love desantis i think
there's some stuff he's done is pretty
awful but in florida he has bumped the
minimum wage which i think is
objectively a good thing and he's a
democrat people
democrats like that and he's put you
know 400 plus million dollars in a
fighting climate change in florida also
a good thing
and i mentioned that and it was as if
i was the root of all evil i i regretted
it immediately i oh it was awful uh
and we can't talk about that stuff
anymore we used to be able to within
reason so
well man those are some some uh too many
facts on your side there there's dark
yeah
i was like why do people like this why
is
santa's most popular governor in the
country
give or take uh
amongst especially amongst moderates not
just the right and i'm like why so i was
just looking into why and that's
awesome
anyway
so so you can help people talk about
politics so you'd say lean into the
humor um i'm i'm considering doing so
um but i was also asked to speak at the
commencement for stuyvesant high school
yeah and i have determined that i need
to be serious for that one oh
so i am
heading down uh
it's it's a fair question
uh you know for whatever reason i
thought poking fun at um you know the
law school grads it's like who cares
they're like adults and the rest of it
um but then for these high school kids
like it just feels like a more
serious occasion for some reason i have
no idea why
um part of it part of it too is that i
didn't go to stuyvesant whereas i did go
to columbia so i could speak very
directly to the columbia experience in a
way that i could poke fun at also
high schoolers aren't going to know that
they're allowed to
i don't think they're going to feeling
like they're not going to be there
ready to laugh right it's a serious
moment for him there's a serious person
there right i think the vibe is going to
be serious yeah tough crowd for laughs i
think i think it's going to be a tough
crowd for laughs um it's going to be
like four or five thousand people in
outdoor stadium too so you're not gonna
get that like if you go to a graduation
center college graduation ceremony
they're expecting an opening joke or two
right that's expected
right so i'm saying this one from high
school i joked half the way through that
thing
joke i thought so i'm going to try and
keep it real because one of my rules and
when in this certification is to keep it
honest
uh i hope that people feel like we've
done that here on the pod
uh and that
i know i i will say zach um and you know
you'll be back with like uh an
announcement about the company and like
back you know when we're back in session
but uh
i've really enjoyed
these conversations with you man when
like like i've looked forward to them
um i hope that people have found value
in them
uh and
yeah i mean we'll be back but if not the
same format but like that there's
there's something too about
uh
like the need to constantly evolve and
do things that
like were you know frankly like work for
um work for people at different stages
um so people from for me
i think you sense that let you know like
i'm
very very uh
deeply invested into
uh trying to push american democracy in
a positive direction i feel like i i've
got an eye on it a beat on it and a read
on it and can contribute a ton of value
um
and so you know like you know stay tuned
uh like i'll be podcasting throughout
the summer
um on mondays uh generally interviewing
various authors and subjects that i'm
excited about as per uge
uh and then thursdays you know we're
gonna like be back after the summer in
some form probably
um you know it might not be zach it
might be some more jewels might be
different things
um but you know like this era has been a
lot of fun man uh in the last nine
months have been great
i saw this quote the other day and it
was uh
it hit me or it stuck with me a bit it
was it's it's cheesy but i'll say it
anyway uh i think it was audrey hepburn
attributed the quote said the best thing
in life to hold on to is each other and
i'd say that's my advice that's my
parting thoughts guys uh
as you go and life gets crazier and
crazier when we watch the decline of the
empire
uh
hang on to the folks you love the folks
that are uh some ways like whether it's
blood or relatives or uh best friends
that are required to stick with you
through it all those are the ones to get
closer to in times like this so
that's my advice man it's been a while
it's been fun you hear what zach just
said everyone he said propose to that
significant other do it that you've been
thinking about hold her tight yeah don't
let her go make her say to you why are
you doing this
and then cave in and say yes the way
evelyn did for me
12 plus years ago still married to this
day two kids she can't go anywhere i
can't go anywhere the way life ought to
be we're stuck
uh and last parting thoughts
congratulations jermaine johnson won his
local race in south carolina kept his
seat they changed the districts up so he
had a bit of a fight there oh he had to
run against an incumbent congrats
jermaine you're the man jermaine we love
you uh we love you guys
be back soon have a great summer
everyone watch some the boys
[Music]
you